[Music]
if there is a border which works like
clockwork
then surely it's here the boundary
between two countries known for their
efficiency the point where Switzerland
becomes Germany and Germany becomes
Switzerland if you're a glass-half-full
type of person you might see this as
slick Swift if your glass is half-empty
well it all looks a bit of a
bureaucratic pain either way it's
certainly not frictionless it is a hard
border an external EU border because
Switzerland remember is not in the
European Union it's not a bad place to
begin a journey to understand what some
worry our borders might look like post
reg settlement this is coming to the end
now of a long long line of trucks
heading from Switzerland not in the EU
into Germany in the EU
it's hardly frictionless you see the
Swiss have rules and regulations which
are very closely aligned to the EU just
like mrs. mais plan for brexit so this
doesn't look good
the journey to our first meeting with
the Swiss customs officers involves
twists and turns through the border
labyrinth Thomas Fischer runs this
border crossing and he's proud of its
efficiency the lorry drivers are
sometimes surprised how fast they can
pass the border in Switzerland
usually they wait on the parking lot
till they make all the clearance thank
you and he gave us the tour the
paperwork usually is done by a custom
agent then he comes here to the German
customs we make here the export
clearance we have to check them because
even the European community has to check
that the law is leave European Union so
this is now this is now the
international transit system and this
works both ways on the other side inside
for export from Switzerland this is the
same then he starts with Swiss customs
and then you go to Germany Castle its
operating pretty smoothly but there is a
border and there is friction yes of
course
whether you see this as efficient or not
the point is even with close alignment
between both sides this is what's
required from boats to trees and
everything in between if it's commercial
it has to be checked in one way or
another for the Irish border which will
become an external border just like this
all sides have said there can be no
physical infrastructure in other UK
ports the infrastructure would need to
be built and that requires time and
space gridlock from day one it would
take a decade to build the more than a
decade to build the necessary
infrastructure that this country needs
on the road north to Calais we meet
Kieran some might call him a white van
man but with over a million miles under
his bonnet he likes to think he knows
his stuff identified by a lot of working
people as well time normal working guy
coming out and dumb down I dumbed down
the customs union two people nobody
understood it
his business is deliveries I'm never
late
I'm never late fast just in time goods
they land in the front through the Mont
Blanc that's true in towards my land and
then down the bottom leg towards Rome
just in time what does that mean
just-in-time deliveries obviously it's
in trucks and vans it will literally
come off your van and straight on to the
production line once you put a barrier
up in the middle of that operation it no
longer sit here no longer it's called a
just-in-time movement you sound like a
right old pessimist just being factual
I've been doing it for 15 years I've
crossed every border 1.6 million
commercial vehicles go to and fro
through the Channel Tunnel every year it
is a fluid movement total trade value
124 billion pounds all the salad that
comes in from the Netherlands the
oranges the cucumbers that come from the
greenhouses of Almeria all come in on
trucks to meet the supermarket shelves
to make sure they're not empty we can
grow our own food I don't see how we can
possibly feed 65 million people in our
country without buying food from abroad
then he says there's all the new
regulation that the UK will need to sign
up to as a third country trading with
the EU you'll need permits you'll need
an international driver's permit you
also probably need a green card
insurance but this is all this is all
project fear people will say you're just
it's never gonna it's never going to
come to pass they'll only realize when
it's happened
the journey has demonstrated that on the
edge of a trade and customs union there
has to be a border and where there's a
border the recuse the challenge for the
brexit brains is to defy that principle
and they haven't got long if you have
been talking to for so long I've got to
put on a train